Now, I understand, one of the books,
tell me if I've got this straight,
one of the books in your book club
is actually being made into a movie.
One of the short stories that we read in my book club,
Belletrist, called First Kill,
is being made into a TV show for Netflix
and I could not be more excited!
I mean, that's huge.
For anyone who, you know, is maybe kind enough
to be participating in this conversation and watching,
you don't just easily get projects
set up at Netflix.
This is a very big deal and congratulations on that.
Thank you.
No, thank you.
I mean, I'm just so excited,
'cause I think people are gonna just love the show so much
and for me, I love to read,
my book club means so much to me
and one of my goals has always been, like,
I wanna make a TV and movies that are as good as the book
and like, that's always been something that's inspired me
and so to get to have the opportunity to do that
and the show is about vampires, which I'm obsessed with,
so it's gonna be really fun, so thank you.
I actually have a copy here of the book
that you have currently, for your book club.
We just announced that yesterday, Shirley Hazzard
and it's a collection of short stories,
which I thought would be perfect for this month,
'cause you can, you know, pick it up and put it down
and the cover is also, I have to say,
I do judge books by their cover and that one is gorgeous.
It really is.
I love that you read from the books on your Instagram
and that we can watch you actually read.
Why do you feel that that's important,
because I find it so incredibly engaging?
Well, I just think, to me,
it's the only way to disconnect, really, these days.
I feel like we live our lives so much on our phones, or,
you know, on our devices or on the computer
and we're always accessible and to me, like,
to be able to take a book with me into the bath or like,
you know, into the park or just to be outside
and like, have something where
there's no, like, alerts coming up,
there's no notifications,
like, I can really just be engaged with one thing
and I feel like it calms my mind.
If I may, I'll start the party.
"The Ferguson's door opened on a burst of light and voices
"and on Evie's sequel of surprise,
"quite as if Minna thought we had turned up uninvited.
"Evie kissed her."
I'm like, all right, I'm in.
I wanna leave.
I wanna go read the rest of this.
I'm in and I also want you to read the whole book to me.
Like, I could just listen to you read the whole thing.
Would it be okay?
I wanna push to your site, which you don't need me,
you have 14.5 million followers on Instagram,
which is all the more reason
that Belletrist is so important
because you will influence so many people
to be passionate about reading
and we're just gonna go bananas on our website
for Belletrist.
Thank you.
I'm so happy that you're following us.
Oh yeah, absolutely.
I think it is just incredible.
Everybody, Emma Roberts.
Holidate is available to stream on Netflix right now.
Emma, thank you so much for taking the time
with your beautiful baby and this extraordinary year,
thank you for coming to our LA studio and taking the time
out of your most important time in, you know,
in your life, right now, to come and do this with us.
No, I was so excited.
I told the baby boy, I said,
"We're going to see Drew today,"
and he was so excited.
Well, tell the baby boy I said hello
and he's gonna have such a great mom
and I'm sure you'll be reading to him,
which is gonna be amazing.
(upbeat music)